if we encounter a man of rare intellect
we should ask him what books he reads
Ralph Waldo Emerson hi I'm Evan
Carmichael and today I'm going to share
the 7 books every entrepreneur must read
these are 7 books that have had a
tremendous impact on my life how I think
about business and I hope they had the
same impact on you now I used to have a
ton of books I used to have walls and
walls of books and when I saw something
interesting I would pick it up and buy
it somebody told me to get it I would
buy it and I found that had all of these
books just sitting on the shelves
collecting dust night and I was
accumulating more books than I could
read and I had great intentions to read
them but I never got around to them and
and they it created stress it created
stress looking at all these books
knowing I got to read all of these
things so I decided one day I would get
rid of them all and I donated them to a
local library and I paired it down I got
to my core list of books that I read and
I reread and I've given me so much value
and today I wanted to share them with
you and hopefully it transformed the way
you think and transforms your business
as well ok well that was awkward
test one two one two at number 7 is the
fred factor by Marc Sanborn and this is
a book about delighting your customers
it tells a story about a postman named
Fred who goes over and above to always
delight his customers which are the
people on his route and you think about
being a postman it could be a boring job
right even the same thing over and over
and over and over again every single day
but Fred finds a way to get to know his
customers to watch over the houses when
they when he knows they're not home on
vacation to always look for ways to
delight and surprise them and so if you
have a business where you personally are
involved in dealing with customers which
will be most people or if you have
people on your team who are responsible
for dealing with customers give them
this book it's a short read look at that
look how thin that is it's like not even
a hundred pages when I'm in pages a
hundred pages just over a hundred pages
super fast read it'll change your
mindset on
I work with customers pick it up at
number six is the go Giver by Bob Berg
and John David Mann this is an awesome
book another quick read it is what a
hundred and twenty-five pages pretty
easy to sift through which you can
probably get through in one sitting as
well and this book is all about giving
and helps change your mindset from being
a taker and saying here are my goals and
I got to go out and take what I can to
realizing that to accomplish your goals
you have to give to other people help
others do what they're trying to do help
others accomplish their goals and in
turn they're gonna come back and help
you and often the path to reaching your
goal is totally unexpected and it's
going to come as a result of helping
other people so it totally changed my
mindset of what I needed to do in
business and not just go and try to
reach and take my goals but to help
others along the path it's an inspiring
story you can't help but feel great
after reading it you can't help but feel
changed after reading it you want to go
out and make the world a better place
it's an uplifting positive awesome story
coming up number six go check it out the
go Giver
coming in at number five is Donald Trump
the art of the deal this is one of my
favorite books because it helps you
think big one of the biggest problems
with a lot of entrepreneurs is you're
stuck in your current bubble right the
environment that you create for yourself
is holding you back where you are how do
you bust through how do you think bigger
how do you go out and do something
that's going to change the world where
nobody in your family has ever done that
before where none of your friends have
that kind of ambition so how do you
surround yourself with those kind of
people you read books like this now this
is one of the first I think it's the
first non-fiction book that I ever read
I was a member I was driving to New York
with my family I don't know how old I
was at the time you know maybe teenager
driving to New York City crossing the
bridge and I was reading Donald Trump
are the deal and it just inspired me to
want to do more to think outside my
comfort zone and this is something that
you need to do as an entrepreneur if you
want to accomplish big things you want
to achieve big goals you have to believe
you got a
leave that you can do it so how do you
get that confidence when you've never
done it and over your families are
nobody in your social networks have done
it you can surround yourself with people
like Donald Trump read this book you
will be inspired you will be ready to
take action you'll be ready to go out
and conquer big dreams they'll give you
that extra motivational boost and you
can apply it to your business check it
out number five Donald Trump are the
deal coming in at number four is
thinking Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill this
book is awesome it says at the top this
book could could be worth a million
dollars to you it's super helpful and
and the main thought behind this is that
thoughts are things there's a lot of
believed in this book that whatever you
have in your mind whatever impact you
want to create in the world whatever
business you want to start it's all
possible it's all possible if you
believe in yourself and it gives you the
steps to do it and it outlines the story
of Andrew Carnegie who was at the time
the richest person in America and his
lessons for success for people who are
coming up how he did it himself
his advice for other people it will help
build your confidence it'll help you
believe in yourself it'll help you make
you ready to go out and do something
positive in the world it'll give you the
confidence and courage to start or to
continue the faith the the motivation
the inspiration that keep going when
when you maybe up against the wall you
not seeing any progress it's beautifully
written great advice in here as I was
opening the book before doing this video
I had the old book smell coming out at
me and giving me a little bit of a
headache so I got her I got a brush out
the book a little air it out it's an old
book but awesome definitely recommend
reading it I know entrepreneurs who read
this every year as an annual ritual and
every year they take something new from
it so definitely go check it out coming
in at number four they can grow rich
Napoleon Hill coming in at number three
keep any promise by Kareem is male this
is an awesome book and it's divided into
two sections okay now Kareem he came
from a successful business but he was
overworked it was causing problems in
his family life it was causing problems
in his in a
health and he totally changed around
everything that he did and replant his
life and he gives you the blueprint for
how to do it now it's divided into two
sections the first are stories of people
and how they've changed their life and
the second are exercises that you can do
to start changing your business and your
life I gotta be honest I'm gonna be
honest is real talk coming straight from
Evan Carmichael is what this channel is
all about the real talk is the stories
in the book I found just okay I didn't
find that inspiring I found the problems
that they were overcoming weren't that
huge and I felt like I wasn't on the
same level with the people who were in
the book and I want to be inspired by
people who are doing more right looking
at Donald Trump and looking at Andrew
Carnegie people who are doing a lot more
that's who I want to be inspired by so
the stories were just okay for me but
the exercises it the exercises are
life-changing that's why it's coming in
at number three if you sit down and you
do the exercises and you follow them the
ones that cream of laid out it will
change your life the huge value here the
show the X's in the book but the big
value is here in the workbook and I hope
I hope cream still offers this as part
of the deal you look here it says
download the life blueprint workbook
$149 value for free that's the money
that if you go through that do those
exercises follow throw in them I
guarantee you it'll change your business
life it'll change your personal life and
a massive impact on me and that's why I
recommend it as a number three book even
if you've never heard of it
it's the secret gem for entrepreneurs so
go check it out keep any promises by
cream Ismael coming in at number two is
radicals and visionaries by Thaddeus
waro and the subtitle is entrepreneurs
who revolutionize the 20th century this
is such an awesome book what it does is
basically tell you the stories of a
whole bunch of different entrepreneurs
and each story is only what four pages
long five pages long so I can I can open
it up and so hear story of Jeff Bezos
there's a picture there's a quick quote
of him
there's his story there's these little
tidbits that come out more tidbits story
and then you're done
so in like four pages you have the
history of Jeff Bezos and how it got
started and it does it over and over and
over again for lots of famous
entrepreneurs that you would recognize
what I found that useful for is it was a
motivational boost for me one you know I
believe model success you've seen a lot
of the videos that I do it's all about
Marlin success and that saved my
business and so this is a quick hit of
tons of different entrepreneurs that you
can model I used it as inspiration in
the mornings for me this used to be my
routine you know when you wake up and
you're you're by yourself and you're
trying to challenge yourself to think
bigger and do more and stay motivated to
run your business
my daily routine used to consist of
opening up radicals and visionaries and
reading one story and I'd get an idea
from them and I'd get get inspiration
and motivated and get some energy from
them and you can do it in a couple
minutes it's such an easy quick read so
you'll get lots of ideas from it you'll
get lots of energy from it definitely
worth checking out my number two book
radicals and visionary status waro and
coming in at number one the number one
book all entrepreneurs must read
drumroll how do I do a drumroll
drum roll the 4-hour workweek by Tim
Ferriss this is my favorite book of all
time if I had to pick one book to keep
this would be yet and at the core this
book is a productivity book okay it'll
teach you how to automate how to
delegate how to eliminate how to
outsource how to apply the 80/20 rule to
your business how to how to be more
efficient get more stuff done so that
then you can go live the life of your
dreams it teaches you a lot about
productivity and since reading this book
I've become a Productivity nut and have
applied a lot of strategies that Tim
suggests in this book to my life to my
business and it's had dramatic impact
the other thing though that you learn
from it is Tim thinks way outside the
box and even now a lot of the strategies
here are still way way way way outside
the box and you don't even realize that
some of these things are possible that
was what I was so excited and interested
in reading from him and this is the this
is the extended an updated version so I
got the original and then I bought the
updated version and if he puts another
one out I'm gonna buy that one too
because it's awesome but it challenges
you to think differently it challenges
you to step outside your comfort zone it
challenges you to look for other ways to
accomplish your goal that you may not
have ever thought possible so on top of
all the great productivity advice that
you get that I get from men of taking
notes and and read through it it also
makes you think more creatively makes
you look for other options and it's an
entrepreneur that's what you're going to
have to do to be successful because
chances are it's not just going to be
the straight path to success it's gonna
be a crazy wild bumpy ride and you can't
just do the things that everybody else
does
you got to be creative you got to step
outside the box that's what this book
helps you do Tim Ferriss 4-hour workweek
the number one book for all
entrepreneurs you must read it now
before signing off I gotta give you my
bonus book it's the only fiction book in
my collection and I had to share it with
you now when people look at bookshelf
you see the Steve Jobs quote at the top
makes sense you see the books I don't
have a lot of them
and when they look at it they look at
the top and see what the heck is that
three kingdoms book what is it all about
and then they look below and you see
this statue and you're wondering what
he's all about
and those little characters underneath
and what they're all about
so I have to tell you the story so three
kingdoms also known as Romance of the
Three Kingdoms is one of the most
popular books in China and all the
Chinese history has then been translated
to English and it'll teach you about
leadership it'll teach you about
motivating people teach about having a
purpose it teaches about honesty and
trust and loyalty and it's a story about
three warring kingdoms at the end of the
Han Dynasty who are fighting for control
of China one of them is led by man named
Cho Cho who was evil and lies and cheats
and steals and is whatever it takes to
win and the people hate him and he's
very oppressive and has tons of rules
and and is and is a you know the
dictator and and his way has to go and
and he's he's evil and cruel and the
other side is run by a guy named Lao Bay
who is fair and honest and just and
treats people with respect and people
love him when they follow him and he'll
never screw people over and these two
guys are constantly fighting and at the
start Lao Bay is losing all the time it
doesn't have the military doesn't have
the money he doesn't have the team and
he's always just retreated and running
away and eventually he builds up his
team and the people believe in him and
they continue to follow him and they
love what he's all about
and and he starts to win and so it's all
about this this fight that continues to
happen between those two kingdoms and
another one that's in the third that
that's not as not as talked about but I
love the story it it always gives me
ideas about strategy about loyalty about
teamwork and I like to pick it up I like
to play the video games I like to buy
the statues that decorate the stuff I
like to name my products after them the
zuga that I sell come from this book
other companies that I've started have
come from this book and so has a lot of
deep personal meaning to me and if
you're looking for kind of an off
wall fiction book that challenges you
that will make you think that'll be kind
of outside their the zone of usual
entrepreneur how to books then check it
out three kingdoms thank you guys so
much for watching goes to the top seven
books that I recommend every
entrepreneur must read plus the bonus
book at the end let me know what you
guys think leave a comment below tell me
what your favorite books are and if you
like the channel you want to see more
you can subscribe thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon and believe
coming in at number four is thinking
grow which thinking Grow Rich they can
grow rich coming in at number four is
thinking grow it grow which grow which
what can I say grow rich grow rich grow
rich okay again coming in at number four
okay me me me me me me make sure to
check out my nose letter yeah got 11